bonsoir à vous trois soirs daniel
d'abord vous qui êtes à ottawa qui avait
couvert ce parlement qu'on entende année
une journée difficile
j'ai envie de jouer un peu les casses
pieds selon ya 44 ans je débarquais
assez calcia montréal en plaît au plus
fort de la crise d'octobre vous assure
que la tension à ce moment là la crainte
la peur était probablement supérieur à
ce qu'on a vu hier à ottawa même s'il y
avait presque l'état de panique ici
aussi dans ce qui m'a le plus dérangé
hier jeu honnête avec vous c'est quand
j'ai appris que l'école de mon fils
était verrouillée qu'on n'avait pas
accès et qu'il fallait attendre que les
autorités policières libère tout ce beau
monde mais bon mes professeurs retraités
avec sac chanel et tout s'est bien
terminé ouais c'est quand même beaucoup
de tension et beaucoup d'inquiétude bon
alors on vient de le voir la sq a retenu
l'attention aujourd'hui c'est notamment
cette espèce de solidarité on a mis la
partisanerie de côté une scène assez
rare tâche à
la dernière fois qu'on a vu quelque
chose un peu semblable s'était au décès
de monsieur frère autiste que elizabeth
may la chef du parti vert a souligné
aujourd'hui avec sur des communes mais
elle a même dit c'était différent et
c'est clair c'était différent on voit
rarement ce type de solidarité même la
période de questions étaient très polis
et très réservé et poser des questions
au gouvernement comment ils allaient
essentiellement protéger les canadiens
s'étaient vraiment je pense un moment
très sobre et aussi qui je pense
rappeler à tout le monde que ils sont là
pour pour le peuple canadien et la vie
la vie est très courte parfois je pense
c'était un moment très humain pour le
parlement très humain est ce que ça peut
durer michel
eeckhout et je pense que tout le monde à
ta voix était sincèrement consterné par
ce qui est arrivé mais tout le monde
sait aussi qu'un événement comme
celui-là ne peut pas ne pas avoir de
répercussions politiques quand quand
l'opinion est frappé de cette façon là
il est certain que il ya des
positionnements dans l'opinion qui vont
qui vont s'opérer pour l'opposition
c'est extrêmement délicat comme
situation quand arrive une crise comme
celle là tout naturellement tous les
regards se tournent vers celui qui prend
les décisions pour vers le gouvernement
qui à ce moment là invisible était
absolument extraordinaire alors le
policier on ne peut pas se permettre de
poignarder le gouvernement dans une
situation comme celle là mais en même
temps ça doit être très vigilantes pour
la suite des choses alors c'est une
solidarité qui est un peu quitte une
figure imposée à ce moment aussi mais la
suite des choses va être tout aussi
délicate pour de position mais qu'est ce
que ça a changé qu'est-ce que ça va
changer au pays on peut parler déjà de
la sécurité peut-être parce qu'au
parlement on a beaucoup souligné le fait
qu il ya beaucoup de questions qui se
posent sur la sécurité qui était assuré
hier daniel est ce que est ce que ça va
transformer un peu la façon dont on est
habitué de vivre le parlement est un
endroit très ouvert très le public peut
y aller vialli très facilement
aujourd'hui
par la force des choses oui les ça va
changer ne serait-ce que les corps
policiers m'ont demandé plus de pouvoirs
pour pouvoir exercer une surveillance
plus accrue plus plus plus efficace à
plusieurs députés aujourd'hui disait ça
ne doit pas changer ça doit rester le
grand rendez vous de la démocratie y
avait aussi me disais tout à l'heure des
députés conservateurs qui souhaitent
très fortement qu'on renforce toutes les
mesures de sécurité au parlement est
partout il ya des dangers de deux
attaques terroristes à se demander si
certains d'entre eux ne souhaitent pas
l'établissement d'un état policier il
faudra bien dosé tout cela et c'est là
comme dit michel quenot position haut
rhin rhône thomas plus importants joués
et pour reprendre sur ce que michel
disait si vous me permettez un céline à
il ya un chroniqueur au canada anglais
très respecté très connu la ruine
smartphone pour le nommer du globe and
mail qui écrivait cet après midi le
grand gagnant politiquement par là c'est
peut-être pas le bon moment de faire de
l'analyse politique ne serait
intéressant de gangania stephen harper
et c'est à se demander s'ils n'en
profitera pas pour aller chercher un
mandat accrue sur la sécurité lors
d'élections avant les fêtes c'est ce
qu'il a écrit avant les fêtes a chargé
luce auger lui c'est cette chronique
aussi avec tout le respect pour paul
laurens on écrit pour pour le même
journal
en ligne à part la turquie ce point ca
mais je pense que c'est pas le moment
d'analyser qui gagne qui perd je crois
que oui certainement au fil des jours on
va voir si si si et désert qui se
répètent horriblement c'est possible là
je pense qu'il va avoir des demandes non
seulement du gouvernement mais du peuple
canadien à ce moment si le gouvernement
déjà planifié de resserrer les mesures
de sécurité il n'avait pas besoin d'un
attentat comme ceux là pour faire la
demande au parlement ils allaient le
faire le projet de loi était déjà
déposé à l'ap a déposé mais a mentionné
alors on sait que ce sont venus c'est
rappel essentiellement à la confiance
des canadiens que ces choses là peuvent
arriver mais c'était pas essentiel pour
faire la cause du gouvernement mais ça
peut ouvrir c'est vrai une fenêtre
extraordinaire je me souviens la
comparaison peut-être un peu boiteux la
cause du tragique de l'événement mais
souvenez-vous la crise du verglas en 98
ou avant la crise le parti québécois
était était en chute libre mais en
dégringolade à ces dix ont soutenu et un
mois plus tard monsieur bouchard qui
avait été à la télévision tous les jours
et qui était vraiment le grand timonier
auraient dû déclencher des élections à
ce moment là et je pense qu'il aurait
remporté une victoire beaucoup plus
convaincante que c'est ce qu'il a fini
par emporter quelques
occasions avait aussi récupéré avait
aussi récupéré la crise d'octobre lui
avait dit être allé beaucoup de
roulement avec les positions de la loi
sur les mesures de guerre si c'est
difficile de
comme ça c'est çà et là ça c'est la
sauver en argenté ça a sauvé son
leadership et ensuite la remporter les
élections mais on sait tous qu'il ya des
moments comme ça mais ceci est un moment
comme ça qui arrive ça dépend est ce que
la personne qui est là est l'auteur de
ces événements regarde monsieur bush et
la crise de catherine fait complètement
opposés on pourrait dire alors c'est ça
dépend de monsieur rappelé comment ils
gèrent cette situation c'est pas de
garanties qu'il va gagner dans cette
situation là oui mais pour revenir à la
sécurité hier soir à cette émission j'ai
duceppe disait qu'en situation de guerre
toute personne se livrent à la
propagande en faveur de l'ennemi on
parle ici du groupe armé il t'a
islamique peut être traduites en justice
éventuellement condamnés donc un appel à
renforcer les mesures de surveillance de
sécurité
est ce que est ce que est ce qu'on voit
est ce qu'on va trop loin quand on dit à
daniel écouter est-ce qu'on va trop loin
moi je pense que la ligne elle doit être
tracé là où s'arrêtent les droits
individuels et là où comme où commence
la sécurité d'une collectivité d'une
population là où commence aussi le
crémeux à partir du moment où on a le
moindre doute qui a des intentions
criminelles que plusieurs explications
nous laisse croire qu'ils pourraient y
avoir des intentions criminelles
il ya quelqu'un quelque part qui doit
agir je suis je suis conscient que les
âmes sensibles vont dire à nos les
droits les droits les droits sauf que
sauf que où on trace la dei à partir de
quel moment on se dit bon là c'est fini
des droits individuels ya un danger réel
et on intervient mais il faut faire
attention à la façon par exemple dont
monsieur duceppe a exprimé sa je trouve
que c'est excessif parce que écouter la
propagande à ça il ya plusieurs
définitions à ça est-ce que par exemple
le simple fait d'être opposés à une
intervention contre l'état islamique
devient de la propagande pour l'état
islamique moi j'aurais peur de laisser
monsieur à peu faire ses interprétations
là souvenez vous que ça peut aller vivre
à plein d'organismes
non gouvernementale qui par exemple vrai
dans la
dans la bande de gaza simplement parce
qu'ils considéraient que ces gens là il
ya eu des contacts peut-être avec le
hamas avait de la graine de terroristes
à la cc je pense dangereux de d'ouvrir
des portes comme celle là sans des
balises extrêmement précises mais il
avait raison dans le cas de la masse on
sait tous et un organisme terroriste et
les gens qui soigne un dé qui soigne un
des femmes dans la paix dans la bande de
gaza là étaient pas des terroristes oui
mais michel il faut tracer une ligne je
passe ici ce qui va arriver et on est on
sait déjà mais si trudeau l'a mentionné
dans le parlement aujourd'hui la période
de questions il a dit déjà on peut
arrêter une personne c'est une actrice
une l2 essayé de partir du canada pour
participer à des effets des actes
terroristes ailleurs ou de faim en faire
un entraînement terroriste alors il ya
des choses qui peuvent être faits c'est
la question de ressources alors là je
pense aussi c'est pas simplement une
question de resserrer les lois mais de
donner les ressources aux policiers à la
grc et autres pour qu'ils puissent
effectivement mettre en place ou faire
valoir ces voix là bon maintenant ces
événements vous savez ils ont fait les
manchettes un peu partout dans le monde
la question a été posée ailleurs mais
pas encore vraiment chez nous c'est à
dire le canada est-il en train de payer
le prix de sa de sa participation aux
frappes aériennes en irak donc 1,7 à
cette guerre en irak daniel
il est évident il est évident que le
gouvernement harper et on aime ou on
aime pas beaucoup plus militariste que
les gouvernements précédents il est
évident que la politique très très très
très très s'aligner sur israël ne plaît
pas à la plupart des pays du
moyen-orient et les il est évident qu'il
ya un climat au canada qui n'existait
pas auparavant
est-ce que ça favorise le terrorisme
probablement oui ça n'aide sûrement pas
sauf que il ya des causes à mon avis
beaucoup plus profonde yahya yahya une
propagande qui est fait par les groupes
islamistes qu'on connaît qui atteint de
plus en plus les canadiens qui les
incite à agir mais c'est clair que le
contexte
et
ouvre la porte à ce genre d'événement
michel oui je pense que d'une certaine
façon on peut dire qu'on paie le prix de
cet engagement là la question est de
savoir à ce qu'on veut le payer parce
qu'ils sont prêts à le payer mais par
exemple toute la question des passeports
ce que le commissaire de la grc dit
aujourd'hui le passeport le fait qu'on
ait pas voulu accorder ce passeport la
rôtissoire de tahoua est ce que c'est ça
qui a été la principale motivation ça va
être un peu la même chose à saint jean
est ce que par exemple si le canada
n'était pas entré en guerre contre l'
état islamique
la frustration de ne pas avoir de
passeport se serait traduit de la même
façon à ce qu on serait allé se
retrouver des militaires abattre je ne
suis pas certain dans ce sens là on peut
dire que oui c'est une conséquence de
l'engagement du canada tasha est-ce que
j'ai une certaine façon le canada est
pas rentré dans la cour des grands c'est
à dire qu'à partir du moment où on
participe à une coalition avec des pays
comme les etats unis la grande bretagne
ben on subit les mêmes on a les mêmes
craintes on vit avec la même peur du
terrorisme ce qui était pas tout à fait
le cas au canada jusqu'à présente mais
je pense que oui on joue dans l'echo la
cour des grands et c'est ce qu'on doit
faire ici écoute la menace l'état
islamique ce n'est pas simplement
réservé à ces pays là c'est oui il nous
cible probablement plus parce qu'on
s'est engagée directement contre eux
mais c'est la chose à faire et il faut
avoir le courage de dire écoute c'est un
état qui tue qui torture les femmes les
enfants n'importe qui c'est épouvantable
ce qu'ils veulent faire et je pense que
le canada est en droit de dire que ça ne
devrait pas se passer et s'engager et si
on paie un prix pour préserver la
démocratie
malheureusement oui c'est un prix il
faut nous qu'on soit plus vigilant ici
pour minimiser la chance que cet acte
horrible se répète là où là où le canada
est menacé à mon avis c'est par des
incidents comme ceux des deux derniers
jours ce qu'on appelle les jeunes loups
ses joueurs individuels qui arrive de
presque nulle part en tout cas pour la
population et qui commettent des crimes
que vous connaissez parce que quand il
s'agit de deux grands complots
terroristes a habituellement ils sont
assez habilement déjoué et en angleterre
en france aux états unis rappelez-vous
au canada amènera femme qui avait tenté
d'entrer aux états unis avec une voiture
bourrée d'explosifs rappelez-vous le
groupe des 18 à ton retour ample et vous
récemment à ceux qui voulaient faire
sauter un train de via rail ils ont été
déjoués il ya plein d'informations qui
circulent ce sont des complots qui
s'organise bien toutes les forces
policières finissent par savoir ce qui
va se passer et peuvent les déjouer mais
des incidents comme lundi à saint-jean
et comme hier au parlement ça ça
pourrait se répéter je peux jouer les
prophètes de malheur je souhaite que nos
mais ça c'est beaucoup plus difficile à
contrôler quelques secondes en terminant
michel le mot de la fin oui ben écoutez
monsieur trudeau hier faisaient ce
qu'ils paient pas vrai de dire que le
canada a perdu son innocence je pense
que monsieur trudeau avait tort le
canada d'une certaine façon a perdu son
innocence beaucoup de gens et monsieur
trudeau lui-même voyez encore le canada
comme toujours de le messager de la paix
là qu'on avait connue est de toute
évidence à cette heure là est révolu
alors le canada après didier perdu je
pense son innocence cette semaine bien
on va s'arrêter là merci beaucoup à vous
trois
la semaine prochaine